now more of my exclusive interview
earlier this evening with Vice President
Mike Pence at the White House we learned
not to trust polls all that much back in
the 2016 election but much of the media
just cannot stop obsessing about the
president's relatively low popularity so
I asked the vice president if the tax
reform triumphs will lift the
president's approval rating why do you
think the president's numbers are where
they are again all polls not just one
including Fox's poll even a tease in the
30s that's the lowest point of any
president at this point in his first
term I'm not all about the polls believe
me but all things considered it's better
to be popular than not so going into
this new year midterm elections the
generic ballot every poll shows
Republicans down double digits right
what do what does the Trump pence team
need to do to tell this story to
suburban women to Millennials to African
Americans to Hispanics are you going to
go to those places even hostile places
that people don't like you very much and
sell that story well first let me say
one of the enduring lessons for me of
election 2016 was don't believe the
polls remember a poll that had us
anywhere close to winning and president
Trump won a historic victory and so
we're skeptical about what the poll
numbers the turnout and the Alabama when
the president was if the president was
sitting here what he would say to you is
we're just going to keep delivering
they're gonna keep talking they're gonna
keep resisting
we're gonna keep delivering and and as
the American people see us with a
stronger America at home and abroad a
safer America you think about the
progress on the international stage in
the last year alone our NATO allies are
contributing as never before
North Korea's been isolated we put Iran
on notice and pulled out and not
certified the Iran nuclear deal
and and the Isis Caliphate has collapsed
we've actually taken that in Raqqa we've
taken back with a with the the capital
of their so-called Caliphate was thanks
to the courage of our armed forces and
the leadership of our commander in chief
we've made incredible
progress so I asked the question about
the poles that is an unbelievable record
in one year I think by any standard if
people are being objective but the media
the you know the establishment media
doesn't want to give a shred of credit
to this administration and many of them
are actually crediting the Obama
administration for the economy believe
it or not so they're getting credit so
they're getting those numbers up I know
you don't believe in the polls but you
don't think that's important in the
midterms with these critical Senate
races given they get a lot of people
want President Trump to resign you've
got a building movement to investigate
him on sexual harassment allegations in
the Senate in the house don't you guys
need that House and Senate Majority yeah
well let me let me be clear I'm
skeptical about what the poll numbers
are but I think you can count on the
fact this president myself our entire
team we're gonna be canvassing across
the country in the next year we're gonna
be telling the story of the progress
this country is making I really have to
tell you we live in a very divided time
in the life of this nation and I think
the president I truly believe that being
in the most powerful economy in the
world that only grew by 1.8% every year
on average for the last eight years has
created a level of frustration when the
president coined that phrase of the
Forgotten men and women of America he
tapped into a frustration the American
people were feeling that they knew it
could be better
they knew the economy could be stronger
they knew we could be standing again in
commanding the respect of nations around
the world we just needed new leadership
to do it and I truly do believe that as
we go forward that and we tell that
story and the American people see those
results I think we're going to see some
of this division in the country begin to
wilt away as we see economic
opportunities wages begin to rise our
military standing tall and standing
strong again
have you been interviewed by the Muller
team I have not yeah but they this has
been a and I think over the last month
or so it has been demonstrated that key
members of this investigation are
loyalists of
either the Obama administration and/or
Hillary Clinton knowing what you know
and probably what you've seen about some
of these investigators who are still
working in this office do you have faith
that this will be a fair and impartial
investigation going forward
well let me say we're fully cooperating
with Special Counsel and will continue
to but but I have to tell you it's just
not been a focus of mine or of this
president I think the reason you saw us
passed the largest tax cut in American
history I think the reason you've seen
the progress of a stronger and more
prosperous America at home and abroad is
because whatever Washington DC has been
focused on this president myself our
entire administration been focused on
where the American people are focused
and so will will will let the special
counsel do their job and continue to
sort through all those emails the
addition emails we're gonna continue to
focus on our job and I think that's
exactly what the American people want us
to do but that does take up times you
have to do document production you have
to you have to you know consult with
counsel I mean a lot of people in the
White House they have to hire lawyers
and I mean I remember working in the
White House as a young 20-something in
this building and I mean I didn't have
to hire a lawyer thank God but that
might not that must not be very fun and
a lot of Republicans think this
investigation is proceeding in an unfair
manner because of the types of
investigators that are on staff and it
continues to be a problem for a lot of
people I can just tell you and your
viewers that were just we're just going
to continue to cooperate Christmas they
should know we're going to continue to
stay right focus where they want when
I'm traveling around this country I got
to tell you it in this again present
company excepted when you're traveling
around the country people are sticking
their hand out shaking their hand saying
thanks for what you're doing for the
military tell the president thanks for
what he's doing standing with law
enforcement tell him thanks for what
we're seeing in this economy once again
I mean people are standing tall again
and on a day like today when we see the
Congress under president Trump's a
leadership past the largest tax cut in
American history the biggest tax reform
not much for the divided 3190
came together I got to tell you it is uh
it's humbling for me to be a part of it
and we're just getting started